[Music]
okay so first I'm really excited to be
here with you I know it's hard to
compete with the talks near near the
tracks I would have problem with witches
also but I hope you won't be
disappointed
okay so let's start you see agenda I
think you had a few minutes to came up
with it so let's start I'm from future
processing
I'm developer and researcher and we are
hiring a few hundred people in on the
south of Poland in our offices in
Griffith Santa Paula and I specifically
work in a special team called
Heartbreakers you will see why and
mainly we are dedicated to innovation
and fast prototyping so that's why
machine learning is our main one of our
main tools
I'm also engaged in the scientific
community as a PhD candidate of computer
science in solution University of
Technology and i/o men of my skills and
interest to transfer University in
England highly recommend it so and what
is your quest you should ask like my
Monty Python's so my quest here is to
save your time and the beginning of your
projects save your time in research in
looking for tools and save your time in
in life because that's important if the
time is the most important thing I think
I think so ok so maybe let's start from
my toolbox so for many months of my
research and development I carefully
refined my toolbox I change technologies
change tools and that's what I've got
now I think for now it's quite optimal
setup so when I come down for multi
environments it's quite obvious for me
Jupiter because I just think it's a
great tool and OpenCV I'm really into
OpenCV like it one it's one of my best
tools always I don't even imagine work
without open CV when we are talking
about images and to my current answer
flow so the main two answers our
community and Google so I have written a
like a very simple Internet crawler okay
that's the Jupiter and that's the
results count of search in github and
stack overflow so quite well-known sites
in in programmer society and just I used
few toolboxes for for example of how
many results I can get when I search
force for example tensorflow
or other tool boxes in github and stack
so like you can see tensorflow is like
high very high in this ranking and I
couldn't find anything even OpenCV has
very similar number of queries 22,000 so
this is one one evidence that why I why
choose tensorflow
and then Google so professionals are
making it better okay so why CNN's
because one could ask why do i why do I
even bother to use CNN's or machine
learning for image segmentation like
you've got classic methods man like
connected components threshold in active
it is just better in challenges this
promise twelve challenge is a challenge
to segment prostate it's a man grant
somewhere here are not a specialist
about this challenge was originated in
2012
but they are still open forum for
submissions for results and as you can
see the first three places in this
ranking are CNN's so that's quite a
clear evidence that it is worth it is
worth to go in the CNN especially in
medical imaging because it's sometimes
hard to explain to the medicine doctor
what is neural network yeah but if you
show them the results okay let's let's
do this let's do this if it's so good
let's do this okay so I will make some
life coding that's the second evidence
why CNN I will use simple idk as a basic
segmentation toolbox and I've got
satellite satellite image and for
example I would like to use connected
components to segment roads so what I'm
doing I'm trying to start for example
from from this crossing here this is
this point seven seven seven three two
four here and I will start the algorithm
from this point and this is the result
for these parameters and of course you
can say okay just just select better
parameters
okay so let's select for example five
and see okay five maybe five and a half
okay so maybe radius maybe something is
here I can spend like an hour to just
try to adjust these despair meters and
this is the classic classic method and
you can find these parameters of course
you can spend some work and have some
experience in it and use better method
call this connected component it's not
perfect but I will just propose cnn's
okay the second evidence is just the
popularity like if you try to this is
Google Trends yeah I've got hit logo
here and this is Google Trends and the
second C and I don't need to convince
you that CNN's are the way to go in
multiple tasks not only segmentation
second thing is why Jupiter I fell in
love in Jupiter with Jupiter like one I
have one and a half a year ago and as
you can see there are many of us like
I'm not the only one so it's hard to get
this girl and what do you think this is
deep learning trend so it's very similar
to Jupiter trend if you if you look
closer and tacular thing here in this
Google Trends is this moment this is
Christmas so as you can see Christmas is
slowing down the development okay so
let's start with advances by advances I
mean what what we did in last few years
to make it better let's start with a
simple task if you are familiar with
image classification it will approach
segmentation as a classification it's
like for a first shot so what what you
can do you've got this supplied image
for example multispectral image with
many layers from many bands of light and
what you can do is just split this image
in smaller images sub images and like
inference it through that similar or
classic neural network for
classification there are plenty of them
in Internet so you can just use one and
try to figure out the class of the pixel
in the middle of this sub image yeah so
we've got a context the full image and
try to predict what is in the middle
what is the pixel in the middle just a
classification task it can have few
classes not only to we've got for
example road building water and grass
something like this you can get
different outputs here like a number of
outputs okay and this task I mean this
approach is very simple but it's quite
good in educational way
because if someone from business unit
came to our team and he will he can ask
is it possible with these images I will
give you a missed client client gave me
images and is it possible to detect or
segment this this kind of object so what
we can answer to him at what what we
usually answer is if you as a human can
understand these images like is this
context for example here and now I mean
about context if you as a human can
segment this image so we've got
buildings here with different context
different sizes of buildings and some of
them even for me are not usually very
clear if it's a building Road you've got
here roads this left top this is
actually from a database free database
from Internet and this left I mean right
right top sub image was a road I mean
there is a road somewhere out there so
as you can see the quality of data is
also a problem usually a problem even if
you've got grant roof you you don't
always like believe in this grant roof
it's not always really ground truth
especially when there is human involved
in the process okay buildings one more
okay there should be something different
but okay that there should be the water
for example water in satellite image is
for example black sub image just random
feet around on fin
okay so what's the difference I mean if
you choose one by one context so you are
just classifying one white white one
pixel by context of one pixel this is
just fresh whole linear so we are just
using some kind of linear regression to
find the threshold
and I will use the plugin juxtapose it's
I think it's quite cool you can see the
image after image before and after so
the green pixels did this green mask on
the on the images rolled and this red
mask is building so with basic fresh
holding we can see some results but you
can look closer 9x9 context I think it's
better the separation I think the
separation is better than the separation
in segmentation is what we would like to
achieve usually 15 by 15 yeah I think
butter in roads and buildings 23 by 23 I
think it's the best what we achieved
here and 4747
the context is too too large to eyes and
it's going going somewhere in the wrong
way not not what we wanted okay so
single peak of pixel classification it's
very simple it's educational you can
start with it if you are not very
familiar with silence but it's very slow
in practice and this is the main main
cause our main goal to achieve that you
won't do things faster to save your time
so the second step is autoencoders so
the convolutional neural networks not
for classifying but for recreating or
encoding and decoding the image to
achieve something different I mean it
can be different in size it can be
different visually it can be
segmentation for example like this this
is quite new paper this screen is from
quite new paper and you can see some
residual connections here I will talk
about it later but the main main goal of
the auto encoder is to encode to some
vector to some set of numbers and to
decode with the another network to get
what what we want
just a matter of training what we want
to achieve we can use different
architectures here like VG Google Ned
anything or just your own architecture
to encode and to decode and it's and it
can be even not different architectures
like you can encode with something big
and decode with something small and the
main achievement of scientific world in
segmentation is this unit it became it
has became so popular in last years that
I see it everywhere
like unit is the way to go we can talk
many things about unit but it works it
just works and usually if we get task of
segmentation with try unit what we can
do better okay so let's start with
difference what's the difference in
between the single point classification
and the unit so this is in comparison
here we've got on the upper image single
point classification with 22 23 23
context and here we've got unit so it is
pretty close to the ground truth and I
would I need to add that this is test
image this is not training image or
validation images it test image in both
cases okay so what we can do better if
this feature transfer in units are so
good so we can we can make it more more
more this feature transfer we can use it
in every layer between every layer and
this is the idea of paper densely
connected convolutional networks so just
transfer these features like in unit but
better like the main disadvantage is the
time of training we can train it for
hours that is the depending on the under
our hardware hardware
oK we've got many others many other
architectures the development of these
different methods is quite rapidly
growing and here we've got deep love it
was described by Paulo and Yamraj last
year but the pipe data were so meeting
meet up and you can see it on YouTube
the explanation of the architecture and
the method and what else we've got men
and many architectures and my first
thought my first idea for this
presentation was to show the whole
pipeline like from reprocessing
everything training the network but I
will not show it because I think the
better way is to start from from just
github and nifty nut so I will introduce
nifty not it's quite new repo from April
but it's quite rapidly developing
rapport like 1500 comets two of them are
mine and they've got great supporters
from mainly from England and I think
they roll they wrote four or five papers
using this using this environment and
it's free it's a posh apache license so
quite quite well in in even business use
cases okay and we've got their whole
process available for you like for
pre-processing for different
architectures different sampling with
these sub images or with whole image and
resizing so it's quite easy to start
from today you are just you know just
taking this repo and compiled or
anything it's in some some parts of our
compiled it but by but in Python you the
most functions are in Python so it's
very easy to use and start and second
thing it's unfortunately it's not
source but personally I have I use it
and it's quite good for rapid
development drop-in prototyping and it's
optimized for industry so if you've got
someone in industry that's recommend
because this is product of our company
okay and github
god bless get half I would say we've got
everything nearly like after three
months after paper usually you've got
implementation on github so just update
update update and here you've got
examples of what I said of units and
instead this signet yeah use so under
one of the slides and D plop and you can
check always this awesome semantic
segmentation github this is like refined
list of the best architectures and it's
constantly updated okay and before we go
deeper so in 3d I mean deeper in 3d I
want to introduce k 3d Jupiter it's
quite a world premiere of this software
and two of our developers from my team
are committing to this actually our main
authors of this of this repository and I
will show you a short introduction you
can you can just download it from github
in few days you should be able to just
pip install it people install k 3d with
small letters okay so quick overview in
another notebook I will run everything
okay so what you've got here you've got
WebGL based visualization of lines
vectors points meshes what else
managing Martian cubes it's quite useful
is for algorithm I will show what what
it can and this is the result so we can
just maybe fullscreen it check the
points vectors it's a sample you can
this is one of the examples in in the
github repo so he aligns different
points you can change the window and
just put it somewhere on the screen ok
and you can for example change something
in interactive mode of Jupiter so this
tool is for 3d visualization in Jupiter
it was what what was missing for us for
our team and I hope it will be useful
for you and it's quite cool even if you
are data scientists not only image
person because you can make this PCI or
this D as an idea Sahni and just use it
in 3d space not to displace as usual so
you can show these clusters in in a one
dimension one dimension more okay this
was quick overview okay I see the
greeting great we'll update but what is
the main goal usually in 3d segmentation
is a medical segmentation medical images
from city and our magnetic resonance so
I will show you one of the use cases of
our team this K 3d
okay life demon i will restart colonel
I think it's yeah it's Jupiter notebook
it crushed oh okay let's wait oh yeah
it's not crushed but we have to wait
some time because this volume you will
see this volume is 500 by 500 by 300
voxels Trender and just we need to wait
because it was not in cash actually okay
so we get hurt
he's just segmentation I would say by
Martian cubes and to understand what is
going on here okay this is marching
cubes at level 1 and by level I mean the
level at the Hounsfield scale this
Hounsfield scale here I think Jupiter
notebook is playing with me because I
have no scroll now here okay I live demo
is bad but I will try to do something
like this okay so we've got here this
Hounsfield scale and the level of one I
mean the level of between water and
blood and this level is if the voxel in
this 3d volume is one you will get
everything that is one and over one by
this marching cubes like segments or
this is a surface you can see here okay
this is something like it's a surface is
a surface over the Hounsfield of one
some Martian cubes with is a surface
near one okay so we can just check what
is going on here its surface so it
should be it's like a travel to the
inside of the earth
okay and what's most popular thing what
we want to achieve is to segment these
guys here this outer is left artery and
right artery and the most interesting
finding in the 3d segmentation is that
you can try to make some pipeline like
from segments in the heart okay let's
wait segments in the heart but you can
also segment one artery single artery
that you're interested in I will try to
run it okay we can also try to change
this Hounsfield level to check what what
will happen
I know what is going on I'm not
connected to power and it's webgl vice
so my computer is not really fast now
but yeah here you've got four hundred
hands fields and it should be contrast
the contrast is injected into arteries
to make the better image of the of the
blood in heart not just water of that
but you can inject the contrast to make
it more visible so you can see here the
contrast in the heart with the with the
blood and everything this is everything
what is around this this contrast so we
can change dynamically here the for
example level of this marching cubes and
it will update to show you the on the
side of the same plot these objects in
the plot are like references and you can
change it arguments or parameters to
dynamically update the plot yeah that
was that was my bad to not connect this
computer ok so what is the way in the 3d
segmentation is freed unit and vina the
v-net means volume net so basically it's
the same but with 3d convolutions why
why to choose something else if it works
like I said it's hard to say what was
first a 3d unit or V not the idea is
very similar and the architecture is
very similar but as you can see at the
dates of publication it's not very clear
who was first and as usual we can have
more architectures based on what we know
from 2d it's and I put the dates here to
show you how rapid is the development I
personally try to be always updated but
it's sometimes not possible to be
updated with
their architecture is coming and of the
ripples or the methods and ideas but few
of them are here and you can try three
of them you can try in the nifty net and
this last one is its I think there is
one rap about it but it's not working
very well but this is like intelligent
connected component if you have someone
who can set connected component is good
for medical so we can you can take him
just okay let's make it intelligent like
let's make it teachable
using machine learning ok and note or
TIF practical tip from me it's the
paraphrase of Phil Carleton idea there
are only three hard things in computer
science cache invalidation naming things
and dimension ordering system
dimensional damages is from from my
experience because it seems that it's
simple with to to manage these
dimensions but in Karis for example if
you use tensor flow back end or Fionna
back end you can have problems with
configuration of channels last and
channels first but actually it's not
very bad for you because it is quite
easy to debug because if the channels
last and channels first are not in the
proper proper order in the config proper
value in the config you will get error
just basically usually you will get
error the second thing is open CV vs.
tensorflow
I love open CV I love tensorflow by they
they don't love each other I mean the
dimensions of images are different Vidya
and RGB this is the most tricky part
because we lost like a week looking for
for a mistake in our architecture and
yeah it's it it became that it was open
see via BGR
and yeah we develop we designed it from
the beginning with the
pensively and Kara's and it was working
it was working it was working and in one
I don't know even who but who sounds
someone changed it in in one place to
read the image in BTR and it was
completely crowd we've thought it's like
a different comet or something because
there were there were like 20 comets and
we have to check everyone every
architecture change what what is going
on and the grayscale images so you've
got columns rows column rows and one
this one is dimension of the color space
in tensorflow and OpenCV doesn't have
this this one if if we are talking about
grayscale in OpenCV it just columns rows
and if you are talking about 3d and
medical image segmentation the biggest
problem is the anatomical orientation of
of the patient because it's not always
the same you've got this information in
your file in your NHD file about this
patient you have to manage this these
dimensions and you have to manage it in
code so yeah we spend lots of time to to
make it work good and to manage it ok so
thank you for your attention we are
hiring because I think there is no such
fingers - too many or enough data
scientists in our company so yeah that's
the end thank you
questions thank you okay
okay so thank you very much Oh point
cloud yeah I think I will try I will try
with V naught because point out is a
let's say 3d else okay the point cloud
is a like 3d volume in some way so I
would do I would use V not try to use V
not but I will try also different
methods maybe for for point out if you
can make some cluster in might be like
in this point clouds and we've got
example in k 3d with point cloud of
tikal Aztec temple or something like
this with point called rendering with
points so we can check it okay thank you
very much
you